Thank you all for coming today.
Um,
we're here with,
um,
uh,
Morra Aarons merely the author of hiding in the bathroom an introvert's roadmap
to getting out there when you'd rather stay home.
If I may give a a little bit of a synopsis.
It's largely about being an introvert when you face things that are difficult
for an introvert.
Um,
it's been easier for many of us to stay in a,
in a,
in a corner on our own,
but,
but more his work has forced her to go out and so she writes about how to deal
with this tension as opposed to give up and stay away from it all together.
Please.
A round of applause for Maura.
Thanks David.
Nice to see you.
Well,
how would you describe being an introvert and the challenge you face as a result
of it?
I,
um,
I call myself an ambitious introvert.
I don't know if that phrase resonates with any of you.
I also have a lot of anxieties.
Um,
I have,
I have social anxiety,
I have flying anxiety,
you know,
sometimes for me sort of leaving the house and going out in the world.
Can Be challenging,
especially in these times.
And yet I,
I run a business and I,
I chose to write this book,
which has taken me out of my comfort zone and every way possible because I
wanted,
it's the manual that I wished I had had when I was trying to build my career.
Um,
I didn't know that I was an introvert.
I didn't know that I had anxiety.
I just knew that I cried a lot in the bathroom and quit lots of jobs.
I felt like walking into the office some days was an assault on my senses.
And you know,
as I got promoted in my career,
I worked in political consulting and digital marketing.
And so,
you know,
as the sort of demands increased to run teams,
run meetings,
collaborate,
negotiate cell network,
all the stuff that you really have to do,
um,
I literally just,
I felt like it was an assault.
I didn't know how to do it and I didn't have a manual.
And so instead I hit a lot in the bathroom.
I still hide in the bathroom a lot.
I don't know if you do too.
I haven't been to the bathroom here.
Um,
so I wanted to,
um,
really provide a really practical,
if you see the book,
it's super practical.
There's worksheets,
there's tear sheets,
and we take on business development,
networking,
how to survive a professional networking event.
That's a huge one.
Um,
social media,
right?
How do you get out there?
Everyone says you should get out there,
you should have a personal brand.
Certainly as you grow in your career,
if you take on a more public facing role,
and this is tough for some of us.
Um,
most of the crowd that I see here is engineers,
but as we,
every time we look for a job that that's,
that's an issue.
But also,
um,
people that were not software engineers don't appreciate how much collaboration
as part of the work we do,
we may be able to get by with relatively little if we only go to the things that
we are called to.
But if we have an idea,
we want to promote as,
as you're familiar,
you,
when you need to get someone's attention,
you need to push an idea that maybe somebody doesn't want to put his attention
on.
Um,
and so,
um,
some of some of these things are,
are,
are certainly more relevant to us in ways other than,
than,
than your personal experience directly.
One of the,
the,
the things you've described yourself as,
as,
as ambitious overachievers.
Yes.
So you want to hear is an ambitious over achiever,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it's easy to be an overachiever in ways that are solitary with our field.
Until you get into industry.
When you were an industry,
you aren't just writing a program anymore and then letting the world see it.
You have to interact with everybody else who your software is.
Is,
is,
um,
affecting in any way.
Um,
and uh,
how do you reconcile having that,
that urge to achieve and facing the fearsome,
um,
a dog ahead of you that you're,
you don't want to interact with?
Yeah,
that's right.
And,
and I think for something like,
like,
right,
I would imagine if you have,
if you've written something,
I have felt this way about my passion projects and this is where introverts can
really shine if we are creative people,
which I believe software engineering is very creative as well.
We have the ability to have faith in our project and our work and to carry it to
a certain place.
So how do you translate that?
Not only in being able to stand up in front of a group and sell in that vision,
which is a,
which is an essential skill,
but be able to negotiate with other people to make your thing come to life.
And this can be hard for introverts sometimes because we've gotten feedback
right in our career,
even in school that we aren't heard,
right?
Because we may be talked over a lot.
I don't know how many of you have felt that.
Um,
and of course there are gender and race and age implications and all of that,
right?
Depending on where you're at in your career,
you might get talked over more or less.
Um,
and so I think one of the skills that I had to learn the hard way and that I
encourage companies now to teach is how to help,
how to help that ambitious introvert with an idea and negotiate it,
sell it,
right?
You're not born learning how to code.
You're not born learning to how to know excel or PowerPoint or keynote or any of
these things you're taught.
And so one of the things that I think we have to seek and given companies is how
to birth your idea socially in the office culture.
Google,
many of us perhaps not a predominant direction,
but many of us have not had a very social experience before coming here.
And so many of us are shorter on those social skills and it would benefit from
them.
But it sounds like this is general useful advice for companies to help their
employees thrive
well.
And,
and you have a rich peer culture here,
which I think can be really valuable.
You know,
I always say that it's great to adopt an extrovert.
if there is someone who you see has that skillset,
right?
Whether it's being able to have someone see their vision,
being able to negotiate and listen.
I mean,
one of the things that introverts are really good at and if you can think of
selling in your software project as a sort of negotiation,
is it may be tempting for us to sort of learn to go in and tell everyone about
our project.
But one of I think the natural skills of introverts is that we do absorb and we
tune in.
And so before you sell,
and I have this in the book and the chapter on selling and negotiate,
read the room,
right?
Tune in to the other conditions,
do your research.
We're very good at preparing and the layer of,
sometimes those of us with anxiety makes us prepare even more.
And so you can learn how to use your introvert like super powers to actually
take a step back and sell in a project.
You described yourself as somewhat of a hermit.
Um,
uh,
an introvert.
I'm socially anxious.
I know these aren't,
um,
synonyms.
They aren't distinct.
Could you talk about where they overlap and what the difference?
Introvert is one that I didn't even understand until a few years ago when I
learned from a friend.
There's a lot of myths about what an introvert is.
There's a lot of great books and literature out there and I think it's becoming
much more socialized and acceptable.
We understand that we are born probably more introverted,
more extroverted.
It's not something that we learn,
although most introverts,
right?
We learn how to fake it at some point.
Certainly if we're going to go out and sell or be public in any way.
I was on Boston public radio last week and Jim Brown,
he said to me,
well,
you don't seem like you suffer from introversion.
I mean,
you can make eye contact with me and you're laughing,
and I was like,
what are you talking?
You know it.
It is not.
It is.
Introversion doesn't necessarily mean that you're quiet.
It doesn't mean even that you're shy.
Actually,
if you're shy,
it may mean that you have social anxiety or if you're just a little shy.
I'm an introvert is someone who needs a time and space and does great work
alone.
Who gets that creative energy alone and when you go into overwhelming
situations,
whether it's walking into a whole hotel lobby with lots of fluorescent lights
and noise or an open plan office.
Frankly,
I mean I'm obsessed with open plan offices and I have all chapter in the book
about how to survive an open plan office or pod situation.
If you feel like I do like the you're superman and the Kryptonite is draining
your energy,
you're probably an introvert,
right?
But it doesn't mean you're quiet or that you don't talk.
It just means that you recharge and you need more quiet environment to do your
best work and you like to be alone with yourself,
which I think is amazing.
Social is another layer that I talk about in the book and that I separate out
because many of us,
whether we're awkward as kids or you know,
no one will sit with us at lunch and we have whatever kind of trauma.
We have intense performance,
anxiety and fear of social situations.
Even picking up the phone to call a colleague or a client walking into a
meeting.
We assume people won't like us,
and again,
this is,
this is a real challenge as you grow in your career and you have to sell.
Being a hermit is that it's,
I use a tongue in cheek.
I actually trademarked the term.
I'm a hermit entrepreneur and this is my choice.
I left Corporate America about 10 years ago and decided that I was going to work
for myself.
I started a small business,
successful business,
small business.
I decided I didn't want to become a corporate executive.
I didn't want to have a big career in the typical sense,
I was willing to make less money and have less power systemically because it is
that important to me to work from home.
I mean that sounds ridiculous,
but it really is.
I love to work from home.
I like to be my myself.
I love my favorite day and this may not apply to you as a day without meetings.
And when we were talking about email,
email is also a big sensory overload for a lot of us,
but a day without meetings and time to think.
And so I created a business that allows me to build in days alone,
time to think and then I hit the road.
How do you reconcile being a mother of three with having time alone at home?
It's tough.
It's hard,
you know,
but I actually,
I mean this is,
Oh God,
this feels horrible to admit,
but I have,
I,
I build in my alone time during my workday because,
because when your kids don't care,
right?
Your kids don't care if you need a break.
So,
um,
what I try to do is I try to protect my time during the work week,
actually to get a lot of time to think.
And I justify it by actually saying it helps me run my business.
It's where I have my best ideas.
It's where I come up with solutions and figure out how to pay for things and
hire new people.
But yes,
one of the complications of working at home.
Yes.
All right.
Okay.
Oh,
not everyone's made to work from home.
It's a discipline.
I don't know if you have a work from home policy here.
I think that some people really seek it and some people it drives them crazy.
We were talking earlier about how um,
social anxiety and introversion can be different for women than men broadly.
Of course it's not going to be the same in every case.
Could you talk some about how it differs for women in ways that might not be
obvious to us?
We're not.
I mean I think one of the things that has been really remarkable to me,
and I love seeing so many men here today is,
you know,
my publisher,
I wrote the but sort of geared towards women because that's my bias.
I run a business called women online and I create political and social marketing
campaigns that mobilize women.
But I think what's interesting is that men feel work life conflict,
right?
The tug between home,
the pressure certainly,
I mean this is one thing I talk a lot about in the book.
When you think of sales and negotiating,
and again it's,
it's a bit different maybe in an environment like this,
but you will come up against it.
I think to be that sort of Alpha male salesmen,
that's something that women don't really face.
We face a lot of other biases,
but I've heard from many introverted men at work who feel really frustrated.
One Guy said to me,
I gave a talk last week and Cambridge and he said,
how did the extroverts,
when everything,
he felt in his work experience that because he was more quiet,
he was not your typical sort of get out there.
Kind of glad handler that that he felt he didn't fit in at his office,
which I felt was really sad for him.
So I think for men there are barriers to feeling.
Certainly if you do like me,
you're a hermit.
You love to work from home.
You like alone time.
You don't maybe want to go out and take clients out for drinks or dinner or sal
and all those ways.
That's a barrier for women.
If we are more introverted data show,
we are less likely to get promoted.
We earn less money.
And of course women earn less money anyway.
And we fought to get,
we fight to get heard anyway.
So there's really a double edged,
a double barreled assault on women.
I think who again,
may not present in a typical leadership fashion.
You know,
you only have to look at our politics to see right now.
And I promised I wouldn't get political,
but I can't help it.
That too often the salesperson and chief wins in our culture.
Certainly when it comes to what we see as leadership,
I could not help feeling all during the election that Hillary Clinton is really
an introvert.
And if she could just,
you know,
sell her policies and small groups and connect in an authentic way,
things would be so much different.
And yet we got the sort of man in front of the room talking and selling.
And I think that that's powerful and that extends to every corporate environment
and every leadership environment.
We need to think about that.
And gender as a piece
you,
um,
uh,
wrote that,
you would be more successful.
Uh,
if you went to cocktail parties more or 37% more successful if I went to
cocktail parties.
Could you explain that?
Absolutely.
I mean,
I think it's amazing now,
um,
that we have so many online tools to network and I talk about that a lot in the
book.
Um,
in many,
many business environments,
we are obsessed with networking.
It is,
I call it enlightened bro.
There are guys like Gary Vaynerchuk and Tim Ferriss out there,
you know,
and they're full of tips to solve your like life.
But if you watch any leadership video on youtube,
chances are there is going to be something about getting out there,
about networking,
right?
Still the old chestnuts of never eating lunch alone,
again,
prevalent in our culture.
And if you're like me and you're sort of allergic to this and um,
you go to a professional conference and you know,
think,
oh gosh,
how am I going to survive the cocktail hour?
I just want to go back to my hotel room and hide or whatever meetup group or
whatever you're part of to sort of advance your career and you know,
it's important.
Again,
you can always feel like you're at odds.
So I probably would be more successful if I like networking more,
but I've also made my peace with it.
And that's why for me,
blogging and participating in online community has been a savior.
Because I can find connections online,
I can blog and connect with people who care about what I do.
And it doesn't matter if we're going for drinks at the local Hilton on a Tuesday
night.
You communicate.
I communicate on my terms from bed
terms.
Um,
uh,
you,
you hinted at having a device for people for the most important thing that they
could do when,
when that parties,
could you,
uh,
explain that I was curious what it was?
Yes.
Well,
the last chapter of the book,
and actually if you go on hiding in the bathroom.com,
I have a 16 point guide to getting out there when you have to.
And,
um,
you know,
one of the things that I talk about is,
and again,
this is simple advice,
but it's really,
really powerful,
is um,
that feeling of anticipatory anxiety when you have to walk into a networking
event or you have to go to a presentation or meet a new team or whatever you
feel.
I think it's really important to sort of physically get a sense of yourself.
You know,
actors do this before they get on stage.
They check in with themselves,
they check in with their motivation.
Why am I here?
I feel that all the time I want to be at home.
I don't want to go on this business trip.
I'm scared.
I don't want to walk in this room.
Why am I here?
Sometimes it's as simple as I have to pay the bills.
That's legit.
Sometimes it's,
I care about my work.
I want to share what I've written.
I want to bring this.
So checking into the meaning and checking into your body.
For me also,
and I don't know,
this is different for everyone.
I have clothes that I wear.
I have literally I'll put my lipstick on,
I will put on my armor and become the person who would play me in the movie
because I can then get that person out there.
And then I follow what my friend Doctor Ellen Hendriksen calls the ten second
rule.
And this,
she's a social psychologist.
You can do anything for 10 seconds.
You can even put your feet over fire for 10 seconds.
So just give yourself that push,
walk into the room or walk up to someone and say hi.
Right.
And then muscle memory takes over.
The other tip that I have,
and this is one that I actually talked to a lot of people about,
and you'll,
you'll hear this a lot,
I call it channeling your inner Oprah,
but some people play journalist,
you know,
especially if you're an introvert,
you don't like the spotlight.
Ask people questions.
Again,
tune in to other people.
You don't have to be the best conversationalist to be remembered as a great
conversation list because if you're present with someone and you can ask them
questions,
they'll think that you are.
Um,
anyway,
I have lots of other good,
but one thing I also wanted to say is,
um,
to give yourself a reward,
this is something that you can think of if you're at a professional conference.
Did you know that there are,
I think it's 137 professional conferences in the u s a day.
It is,
it is the most booming industry.
And so,
so again,
the way that we're taught now to network more than ever,
we're also expected to go to conferences more than ever,
which is weird.
I mean,
certainly in tech conferences or like out of control,
right?
So,
um,
for me,
I'll say,
I'll do my research about what I,
who I want to meet.
I'll say I got to meet three people and then I let myself leave.
I sometimes they'll go hide in the bathroom,
I'll go hide in my hotel room and it's okay.
Set a quota,
set a quota or the goal.
Um,
there's a term that you used,
um,
uh,
I didn't get to the part of the book where you explained this term,
but I'm curious what it means.
You,
you mentioned achievement,
porn achievement during,
it's very much
a while back,
I wrote an article in the Harvard Business Review about the rise of
entrepreneurship porn.
Um,
and uh,
I'm glad you think it's funny.
I,
I've been a sort of player on the edges of the Boston tea tech and VC scene and
those sort of women in tech scene for many years now and then in La.
And it's very sexy to be an entrepreneur.
It's very sexy to work at a startup.
It's probably still sexy to work at Google,
you know,
so you guys,
you guys have that.
But as you know from your friends,
whenever you work at a startup or if you found a startup,
it's very sexy.
People want to talk to you.
You're an entrepreneur,
right?
And so the media and networking culture and leadership talks in this whole
conference industry has really glamorized entrepreneurship,
especially tech entrepreneurship,
right?
It's made it seem like that's what we should aspire to and scaling and never
sleeping and tirelessly fighting until we get funded or we grow.
And I call it porn because you know it when you see it right.
You read all these profiles of these young entrepreneurs who would stop at
nothing and made a gazillion dollars.
Very few of us can do that.
Even if we're smart enough for me personally and the people that I interview in
my book and my podcast,
they didn't want to do that.
You know,
some of us wanted to have really great lifestyle businesses.
We needed to step back from the entrepreneurship porn and the achievement porn
too.
You know,
it's,
it's this sense that if you don't give 110% every single day,
you're letting the side down.
So it's the false image.
It's the false image.
It's the glossy image.
Even failure is sort of glamorized because we read a lot of stories about this
sort of epic failures certainly in Silicon Valley,
in New York,
but they never really feel like failures to me.
I,
I don't know about you,
but they for to feel like just a blip in the road till the next big one and life
isn't like that.
You mentioned the,
the Tech Industries,
um,
passion for,
for an entrepreneur who drives a,
an idea and starts a company.
But I feel like we're changing more broadly than that.
More and more people are expected to make their,
their job as you've done,
even without building a company,
just as,
as a sole contributor who is,
who is also the CEO of the company might say.
Um,
and that requires a lot of,
of social networking of sorts as well.
A lot of,
a lot of,
um,
often cold calling to,
to start a business that doesn't exist because no one else has done it for you.
Um,
given that many of us,
well maybe not in this room this year,
but,
but many of the people watching this may find themselves in that state while
looking for their next job,
finding that they need to make it themselves.
If they,
um,
if they prepare themselves to walk into that room,
then they're there.
They're talking to the people and their nerve fills them.
Do you have any advice for how to,
how to pull yourself back together when,
when you,
you feel you're not up to the task?
I mean,
I think it's,
again,
it's about tapping into the meaning and the motivation.
I like to use the metaphor of being a crafts person.
You know,
if you had built a house that this really lovely family we're going to move into
and you had lovingly taken care of every element,
you would be proud to talk about it.
I'm a big fan of of freelancing and consulting,
although there are many things that are bad about it and you probably will make
less money.
You will have maybe less of a systemic impact.
You got to think about healthcare,
but for many of those people are you in five years from now,
if you leave this place and go walk into a room to make it on your own,
even if it is as a consultant,
don't feel like you need to start a fresh.
Often your best clients will be your old company,
the people that you used to work for.
You know,
an introvert's gift is actually managing a network in a way that is good for us
and so I find that we're actually good at sustaining those long relationships.
I have a role called the 10 touches,
which is in the book.
I learned it from my husband,
my favorite adopted extrovert.
But for me,
I can handle 10 business development touches a week.
It might be just dropping you an email,
which I know now you won't see,
but that's okay.
It could be calling someone,
it could be recommending someone on Linkedin,
right?
Making some sort of outward gesture.
I can do all of this from my Home Office,
but if I have the discipline of reaching out to 10 people a week and you can do
this actually while you're working for someone else to help build that network
and help build that future network of potential employers,
funders,
colleagues,
staff,
whatever,
you know,
you can,
I'm a big believer in breaking things down into bite sized chunks,
bearable chunks.
So I do the 10 touches every week.
I keep my network going and so then I'm never so scared to walk into a room
because I know why I'm there.
I try to have a sense that I am not alone in this work,
if that makes sense.
Thank you very much.
Um,
is this a good time for questions?
Yeah,
I think anyone has a question.
So,
uh,
I don't know whether,
you know,
the leadership of Google would consider themselves introverts like very page and
Sundar.
Um,
but they don't strike me as the like,
you know,
usual sort of CEO,
right.
When you see them speaking publicly,
they're not as comfortable or polished.
Um,
I don't know that I have a particular question but like any thoughts about that
and kind of,
you know,
tech leadership in general I guess and kind of where people fall on the
introvert extrovert sort of scale.
I think that's really interesting.
And I was thinking about that actually as I was coming in,
again coming back to the fact that these are skills that you learn.
I think that if you are,
you are gifted and you create an amazing tech company.
And I think of Bill Gates and I think of,
you know,
all the leaders of these big tech companies,
they are not necessarily the most comfortable public speakers,
but they give public speeches every day when they reach a certain point in
leadership.
And I do think they are changing the model.
I think that's really cool.
But what's interesting to me is at the same time we have these leaders who are
changing the model and do seem like they're more introverted and probably would
be much more comfortable in a smaller group or one on one or even behind the
screen.
Um,
we have sort of this flourishing how to culture of conferences and gurus telling
us to get out there.
And so to me it's like actually a little confusing.
You know,
what kind of,
should I be a great networker?
I should,
I just pursue my own passion.
I think the answer is pursue your own passion and you'll figure it out later.
If you're good enough at what you do,
no one's going to care if you don't give a great speech.
And you will notice that when they're talking about things they really care
about and they're really comfortable with,
they come alive,
right?
They don't feel awkward anymore.
I saw that with the professor when I was an undergraduate.
Yes.
Freshmen to sophomore classes.
He was like a robot.
Junior year classes.
He was a fire.
I bet someone taught him or he just liked that class better.
It was the material difference change.
Oh.
Um,
I had a question about,
uh,
so you talked about creating a sort of like space and alone time in the business
that you created.
You have recommendations for how to do that within a corporate environment.
Given that we are in an open layout and there's always a lot of noise around us.
People are always walking around or are you just hear like conversations right
from people that are sitting right next to you?
Um,
yeah.
Do you have a,
I guess recommendations for how to sort of carve out that time for yourself even
in that environment?
Yeah,
that's chapter 10 in the book.
Um,
and,
and to be honest,
you know,
I think that it's a very individual thing.
I hear you,
I hear you on the open plan.
I think that um,
more companies and,
and I don't know about Google and it,
you know,
I'd actually be very curious to know are building in more private space,
especially with the rise of a pod based,
you know,
pod based setups and and sort of agile everything where there is so much
collaborating happening.
Right.
Um,
I think people also understand that individual teams might want a quiet space to
collaborate but that people need a break.
We're all over meetinged I also think the rise of slack and I guess here you use
g chat but you know,
the constant communicating not just face to face but online while we're sitting
publicly is very draining.
I think if you can and you are able to do your best work talking to your manager
and you know,
if,
if working from home is your thing,
if there's a quieter place,
I think many of us are socialized and I totally understand it.
To be afraid to ask for what we need to get our best job done.
But I have some amazing statistics in the book.
Your boss will accommodate you because she doesn't want you to leave.
It's very expensive and it's a major pain in the butt.
And so being prepared,
having a plan and saying,
you know,
I have to get this project done,
I need quiet,
I will do my best work in the quiet.
I'm going to take three hours on Friday.
You have my cell phone,
I'm Gunna be on g chat.
And just trying a little bit of a pilot,
an easing in might be really effective.
But I think not being afraid to say we all feel that way,
right?
It is a very draining environment and so don't be ashamed.
Thanks for coming again.
And um,
I guess first thing I'll say is that Google has some very nice bathrooms,
so it's going to take advantage.
Um,
the question is,
uh,
I guess I find myself in a little bit of a flip of the situation that you
described in the sense that like day to day,
I'm attracting with a lot of people around here.
And outside of that I find like I have zero energy for social networking,
right?
Like for online networking.
Right?
I have zero energy to put stuff even on Google plus internally much less,
you know,
Facebook or Linkedin or whatever.
Right?
And it feels like there are these very big channels of being connected and
tracking with people,
having influenced blah,
blah,
blah.
The,
I'm not participating in because I just don't feel I have this sort of introvert
energy to participate in those.
Do you have any thoughts or suggestions?
I just want to say I hear you.
I feel I feel the same.
I feel,
I feel sometimes that participating online is almost more of a challenge.
Um,
and,
and that you do have to force yourself.
But I would ask yourself why.
I think a lot of us feel this sense of Fomo,
right?
I know I should be doing this.
I should be gaining influence.
I should be building my personal brand.
My question is why fear of missing out,
fear of missing out.
So that's my question to you.
Why?
What's your motivation for building the influence?
And then,
okay,
I want to write,
do you want to,
do you want to make a creative contribution?
Do you want to grow your network for potential future career opportunities?
Do you just want to build your online landscape,
your online footprint in your online profile?
Maybe pick one simple way.
For me it's always been writing.
I'm comfortable writing,
I like to write.
So blogging was so natural for me and I didn't push myself for the other parts
of social media that made me feel naked.
I think that there are ways to build your online footprint that are less social
but equally legit photography,
video,
recipes,
writing.
So maybe start there,
but I think it's also okay to say why,
who says I have to do this right now?
And like baby steps.
Okay.
Hey,
thanks for coming.
Um,
so I have a question sort of on behalf of my partner who's currently trying to
get a leg into a career or doing like animation and she's spitting,
it's at a time building up a portfolio.
She's gonna start applying to jobs soon.
And I think she has a challenge now where she's an outsider looking to break
into an industry where she's doesn't have a lot of connections.
What would you say to someone like that WHO's trying to get into um,
a place where they're networking and meeting people and finding opportunities
when they're starting from zero?
That's tough,
right?
This is where conferences actually can be very helpful and because she does want
to get into a very specific industry,
I mean I would,
I would encourage it to even go a little bit deeper than an animation.
You know,
is there a certain area,
does she want to do entertainment and she wanted to do scientific that she
wanted to technical,
I don't know.
But what I would do,
honestly,
this sounds so basic is I would start on Twitter and use some search term
seeking and find out who's writing.
This is what I've been telling my clients to,
who's writing about it?
Are there animators tweeting who are,
who are people on Youtube who have big followings?
I would start following them and I would figure out what are the publications
they cite or contribute to message boards,
websites and is there a conference they go to?
Honestly,
and then she needs to sort of have a battle plan.
I would challenge her if there's a,
if there's a conference in La for example,
where she says,
you know,
potential employers are going to be there.
This person that I really want to work for,
his speaking,
that's the opera.
That's that.
That's the place where she's got to have her plan and she's got to,
you know,
figure out her online strategy ahead of time.
She's got a good website,
she's got a good portfolio.
Is she following the right people on Twitter,
go to the conference,
have a strategy,
try to meet you know,
five people.
Maybe she can bring an extrovert with her and do it because when you are going
to break in you sometimes have to get out there and sometimes the facetime of a
conference is actually really great.
It just is
awesome.
Thank you.
Typical sorts of things to,
to,
to bring up in a talk like this that don't apply so much to Google.
Are Hauer the workplaces locking in ways that that
makes these challenges greater and how can the companies change?
I would say just in general,
and I don't know if this is an issue in Google,
I've never worked here.
I've read a lot about it.
My personal passion is helping really successful ambitious people claim the
space and the quiet they need to get their job done.
For a lot of people it's working from home,
it's getting out of the open plan.
There was a great reported story on a blog that,
you know,
the apple $5 billion headquarters,
it's all pod.
It's all open plan.
So one of the senior engineers actually had a bit of a palace coup and insisted
he have his own building with private spaces built.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but I was like,
yes.
So if I had one dream for workplaces to change,
it would be that managers stop looking at the person who's always in the office
as their most ambitious person and look at the person who does the best work.
Right.
I,
I feel that,
um,
we,
again,
we equate facetime,
seeming enthusiasm,
team spirit,
all this stuff with ambition and skill.
And that's actually not the case at all.
Um,
if I could have,
you know,
growing through the corporate ladder and worked from home two mornings a week,
I would have been really happy.
So I would like people to stop to decouple ambition from facetime and certainly
from extroversion.
What is it going to say?
I don't know if this is a question or response to something and somebody else,
uh,
asked,
but are you familiar with rest by Alex Pang?
Yes.
I quote it in the book.
Yeah.
Cause he talks a bit about,
you know,
many intellectuals or quiet people or whatever who,
would do an hour or two of work and then go out on a walk for,
you know,
an hour,
hour and a half,
something like that.
And to me,
you know,
I have certainly done that here at Google when I need quiet time by myself to
think about something.
Right?
The problem is you can't bring like a laptop with you and type,
but you know,
around here sometimes that's the only time you can get quiet for 30 minutes.
I just want to acknowledge that and to say,
again,
these,
it sounds so basic,
but the ability to claim your time to think is really powerful.
And I know the Google's always been a leader in that you've had your,
is it 20% rule or whatever,
but you know,
so few places in our life give us a moment to be with our thoughts and get
creative and that's a discipline at work that we need to honor.
Yeah.
Oh,
hey,
another question.
You brought up a Hillary's campaign.
I was curious.
Um,
yeah,
I guess if you to go in to do that,
right,
I'm having those flexible.
How would you have gone about,
uh,
I guess like changing the way that she sort of went across America and how these
conversations.
Oh,
so politics,
I'm just curious.
Yeah.
It's not really like a,
you know,
I had been thinking about this because as,
as a sort of digital political consultant,
I've been thinking and,
um,
there's actually a candidate running,
you should check her out.
Laura Moser in Texas who started something called the daily action,
which is online action.
She's a bit of an introvert,
so I'm going to see how she's running.
Again,
I think that we don't always get the best candidates because so much of being a
politician is that glad handling small talk.
I mean,
if we think walking into a tech networking event is bad,
imagine walking into like a firehouse dinner in a different state and fire has
breakfast every,
you know,
I mean,
oh my gosh,
that's hell for an introvert.
So I would love to see candidates win.
Who could,
you know,
either use online conversations.
You know,
wouldn't it be amazing if you could have Skype conversations,
if you could use all these tools to connect with people in a meaningful way.
Convene smaller groups,
usually small groups or just only high donors get small groups now,
high dollar donors,
and yet politicians are expected to be so extroverted at the detriment to the
skill of policy.
I think this is something we're all going to deal with.
We're dealing with diversity at work,
work styles,
we're dealing with failed styles of leadership.
I think we need to rethink all of our different temperaments and how leaders can
be different kinds of people.
To your point,
and that that will happen in the next five or 10 years,
here's to seeing how the future accommodates and how introverts,
yes.
Thank you very much for coming.
Thanks David.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.